Awwwee, I fucked up. This is stupid-
pewds done gettin a scaredipie
Hey, how's going Bros ? My name-a  PewDiePie !
Today we're playing "Emily Wants To Play". I played this game before; It's fucking scary.
Like, someone suggested this to me, and I was like:
*nope sound*
HELL NO, I'm not playing that shit on VR. I set up a completely different game to play today,
It didn't work, so I'm like "Well. I guess I'm playing this!" We'll see how it goes... Fuck man.
It's gonna be scary. Okay. Well wish me luck. If I die... I die. :)
Fuck this is creepy- Oh my God!
It's a black lady there.
Oh!
*gasp* Where did she go?
Fuck I'm scared, I'm legit scared already, okay.
"Trigger to grab and interact, hold..." Alright, let's just go. FUCK! Okay.
Come on. I can do this. I ain't scared!
(lol nope) Oh my God. I'm scared!(See?)
Your pizza's here! It's PorterPie. Oh my God. What happened?
OH, it's a crazy, bitch!! I better go...
Ah hell, no, I'm so- oh!
Fuck, a painting I can't interact with... Alright we're fine!
I realized I'm looking at a wall. I should probably stay like this, right?
Oh my God there she is!
How you doing there? Don't fuck with me! My God this is scary...
*constipated Felix*
It's giving me the creeps man!!!
What the fuck is happening here?!
*bitch laughs*
OH! >:(
Where did that bitch go?! Where did that bitch gooo?!!?
You better not move boi! Heyy, how you doing down there?
OH MY GOD, that's too creepy. I can't.
Where the fuck am I? I'm so lost.
Aah, I forgot how you played-
Oiiii
Okay, fuck it. The door just opened up, I'm fine.
Fuck, I'm on edge man. I'm on fuckin' edge!
Some games you're not supposed to play in VR.
Okay... hello? HELLO?!
It's me! :D
What is this?
*audiotape static*
Oh shit, it's this fucking thing, turn it off!
*Silence envelops the scene*
Okay, alright. Let's see here. What does it say?
The fuck, what do I keep touching? I'm so lost, Jesus Christ. Okay.
All right, well let's go in here. How's that right- is there light switch in here?
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared!!
"I just want to play!"
Ah, fuck!
Oh-
Who turned on the TV?!
(TV) -"bizarre death of a local couple.
The couple was found lifeless..."
I forgot how you-
that bitch was NOT there before!!
Oh-
What's me- a fuck! This is so scary!
Who made that noise. Is that Santa Claus? I think we're fine.
Oh my God. Oh my God. My God where did she go?
I don't have a flashlight yet.
There's definitely something down there.
I ain't going down there, fuck you
Where's the flashlight I gotta find the flashlight right? Let's play at midnight. Okay? Let's not
That's weird. I'm sweating guys. I'm fucking where's the flashlight. I need the flashlight
Oh, yeah, they turn off the lights right? Okay, I got it. Let's find the flashlight
Ah that's fucked.
Where's the fucking flashlight guys?
Fuck- I ain't down for this shit, man
I really ain't down for this shit.
Oh god is it midnight.
Awww fuck I need to get the fuck out of here
okay well, this is the brightest room. I'm just gonna- what the fuck was that. What the fuck was that?
No!
Oh God
Turn on the light turn on the light
FUCK YOU. FUCK YOU. You aint gonna get this. I know kungfu
Swedish kungfu, Motherfucker
Oh my God this so scary
Bitch, you better show yourself before fucking fist you fuck you.
Oh my God, I don't like this hello. I just want to deliver the pizza
Why did I try to deliver a pi- bitch you fucking fuck off bitch go
What do you want? What do you want?
What do you want bit- you tiny. ah she's tiny guys *screams*
*RIP POPPIPIE*
God damn it
Fuck. That fucking hurt
What happened? I died I- great
fucking great
fuck
Okay, we need to find a flash time this time for Fuck's sake flash flash light
Your pizzas here every-
*creepy laugh*
thank you for telling me how to grab
(how to fist manual)
Okay, let's find the fucking flashlight
Don't see it though.
Aw you fucking bitch. How did you get there? God damn, it's so creepy. No!
God damn, it's so creepy. I can't
That's normal. There's the flashlight. i found it. Oh, fuck
Okay, we have the flashlight now
Hell no
Oh my God can we go down there? Oh, I fucked up. This is stup-
I'm such a pussy jesus Christ
De-ve-ere is la flashlight- ah
Ve-re is the flashlight everyone has anyone see the flashlight
Ehm?
Just poor Swedish man looking for flashlight
That's anyone seen the flashlight. Alright, I go
Maybe it's in here
Oh shit I never checked this room
Fuck you
Alright, lady. I'm here for the flashlight and nothing else
Someone got a blue screen. That's bad. oh look at the notes in the paper thing
"They will never take my friendship-" Fuck!
Ow
what the fuck did I just
Where am I? Ah, fuck. Aw great I fucked up the green screen.
oh great. It's midnight. it's midnight alright. I'm ready for this
I'm ready for that, bitch
wherever she comes
I will fucking kill you. I will stab your eyes out and eat them you better show yourself. Where are you?
Why did you draw a dick? Oh wait it's the controller
No not on my watch the doors stay open
That's right
Fuck okay. I'm getting a little scared
Yes, the child will have no idea what happened hehehe
Bitch, bitch, you fucked up, bitch you go
alright, I'm looking at you. I'm looking at you. You can't hurt me
Said I'm looking at you.  What are you dabbin?
Go dab somewhere else
I'm not going to look away from me because I know bad things is gonna happen oh
oh god.  Where'd the bitch go? Where'd the bitch go?  Where the bitch go?  Where'd the bitch go? Where'd the bitch go?  Where'd the bitch at?
Where them hoes at? The hoes at? The hoes at?
Is there anything I need to do right now? fuck it's quiet
Okay, come on
What the fuck with that?
She's in there
fuck you that door stays open
Bring it bitch. Is that all you got fucking dabbing?
Oh, God. Oh my God you fucking bitch stop dabbing
is that all you got? get off the couch
Go go go whatever
Well, this is fuck. Oh fuck. Oh fuck
Where is she? where the fuck is she? Where is she?
No
You can't fuck with me
where? oh my God you fuck- I hate you. Go away. Go away
go away little girl go play now. You want pizza. well. I got bad news for you. I ain't a fucking pizza
Okay, that's normal I guess
Time is not going forward. I noticed
ah fuck that's dark. Here we go. That's better,
Okay I'm just going to try and keep everything lit- fuck it dark
Fuck you, fuck you *screams*
Fuck this man. I'm so fucking tired. I didn't even want to play this stupid horror game today. Pewdipe play more horror
Yeah, well from now on
I'm just going to play what I want to play okay? Conrad the kitten. Oh my God
It's him and so cute! Oh, you're so cute
You're such a cute puppy Conrad
I love you, Conrad Conrad you're the best cat ever- that's right pewdipi
I am- oh my God it speaks
Look at him. He's so cute. You can do backflips
All right, here you go Conrad
Okay, I guess not Conrad. How we grill you?  Where do you want to go? What do you want to do?
Why why aren't you listening to me conrad? Can you walk can you do anything? You're the worst cat
You're the worst cat Conrad
Conrad
Move move Conrad, what do I do with you?
Fine, let's go to the fucking kitchen. You like the kitchen? Huh? All right? What do you want?
You want some food eat it eat the fucking food Conrad take a shit while you're at it
What are you doing, Conrad?
This is not how your poop Conrad?
God dammit, Conrad I wanted to chill out with you. You know what Conrad? Fuck you Oh my God
Oh my god
What have I done?
Leave a like to die instantly,  I'll see you bros in tomorrows video. *kisses*   and as always stay awesome, brochachos